I just want to remember Rodney for a
minute because you're someone who had a
moment with yes you get that movie yep
and you go there back to school yes and
you get that movie and you have to go
over meet Rodney and Rodney's for he
opened it first of all I can't tell how
many people told me that when he walks
in a room he immediately always shows up
in a robe or pajamas and his balls in
Decorah and from what you say Rodney had
you'd balls balls yeah and then and you
smoke weed Ronnie I would think I did
not smoke because I was pretending that
I didn't need to smoke weed every 20
minutes right and that would have been
bad but Rodney sat there and smoked by
himself to the best of my recollection
yes no kidding how many hours do you
spend with Roddy or is it just like a
ten-minute meet-and-greet I don't recall
much besides the cojones and why was the
movie so much fun did he make it fun or
it was a I mean Kennison was did you
meet Kinison of course yeah and yeah it
was young and I mean everybody and you
know everyone was great on that it was
great it was also I mean come on for
when you're looking at the back nine
it's all a period piece so I have my
memories of shooting something in the
80s where it was everything was
completely awesome right but I do
remember we were shooting some scene in
in Madison Wisconsin and and I think it
was like a Thursday or something Emmer
do is I heard of like a checkout line at
a supermarket or something and he goes
oh oh my ankle I was like your ankle he
goes yeah yeah I don't know if I'm gonna
make it into more you know what I mean I
was like really he goes yeah yeah yeah
yeah he you were around tomorrow
I was like yeah goes maybe they'll shoot
some of your [ __ ] I was like wow he just
told me that he's going to feign an
ankle injury so he has a three-day
weekend and do I mind covering for him
when the first day these scrambles to
figure out what they're gonna shoot
isn't that fantastic yeah
oh my he winked at you and goes oh my I
think my ankles swollen you nor me I was
like oh my god is it occasion not really
come here come here come here what the
hell did he have to go do he's in the
middle of shoot moves a very active
fella he seemed he seemed to have plenty
to do
right beside shoot yes
you